alright so years ago this is a real
typical question in some ways
differentiate into doing something so it
shouldn't be too difficult but there are
some twists and turns which arrived and
asked this question I think it's um it's
quite a long with unit really enough
Zambia especially can do it properly
okay yeah why don't you borrow from
someone right now and then go get it won
by a little girl lying paper for 40 okay
pi day we can all do so you tell me
what's arrived what am I going to put
down first come on guys you could have
done this months ago whatever kind of my
love to earlier songs okay sure it's
it's a question right so I'm gonna go
this is my you and this is my V okay so
let's just reverse question rule okay v
u dash yes okay good minus u v dash so
far so good right okay on what still
awake what's on the bottom I say what's
on the top
ok so I'm done there's not much else we
can do that no I trust that will help
anyway okay all right now papi here's
where the fun begins now before I
actually you start you know I mean
usually you'd write this down okay but
it's a hint so we're building on what we
got from this part here okay from part a
so this is the result that I established
that the derivative of that function is
equal to this okay so what would you
suggest would be our next step what
should I write down remembering this is
what I'm trying to work out okay I could
do server I could do some substitution
right um why would you do why would you
I mean keeping you keeping in mind that
we know we know I mean the whole point
of establishing district is so that you
can establish a primitive function for
this which isn't a standard one okay if
I've given you this and say okay
integrate from there it's sort of I mean
that's not a normal function of expect
you to recognize ok so now I've
established that this all right yeah
this is the primitive of this okay so
how am I going to use that fact previous
question okay I should integrate right
now I'm not just going to integrate
anything yeah I'm going to integrate I'm
just certain boundaries the question is
on a certain boundary right okay let's
do the right-hand side first i'll just
write that down you integrate this
should not 21 with respect to X so
nothing to come at it okay now what will
I write on the left hand side
remembering that this is a definite
integral
I've integrated the right hand side with
respect to X from not alone when i
integrate this with respect to X from LA
to one what am I going to get I'm going
to get square brackets right because
this is the primitive but I want to
evaluate it from certain boundaries okay
if I don't evaluate like you know if I
just do the indefinite integral what
difference would it make I'd have I'd
have you lose these boundaries you lose
the 0 to 1 square brackets you know x 1
plus x squared plus the cost of
integration okay but since it's a
definite integral I don't have to worry
about the consulate right now okay so
what I've got here let's just make that
minus out of here this I've written is
is one fraction okay but because I've
got two terms on the top I think just
break that apart into two fractions yeah
okay but before I do that hmm I think
that's going to cause me some problems
right it's going to cook me some
problems because how about have a look
at it um what I want over here is the 1
on 1 plus x squared or square that's
okay that's what I'm that's the part
that I'm after okay what what but have a
look at what you're going to have on the
on the bottom okay now i'm just going to
write this up on a separate color so you
can see the issue that i'm trying to
draw your attention to ok this is you're
going to break it into this one 1 on 1
plus x squared squared there's the first
part ok no no I haven't finished the
interview yet ok so I've got you know
there we go I'm and then I've got this x
squared on 1 plus x squared square ok
now before I go any further ok I want
you to stare at this through a little
while
okay this guy I don't know what it is
but that's kind of the point that's the
question okay so I'll leave him for now
now have a look at this what is this um
what interval is this what's what's the
primitive going to look like now before
you like some of you in the next one or
two minutes you'd be like ah I see it
okay but the rest of the view let's try
and process because this is why this
question comes at the end of the exam
okay this is not a standard form okay
well this is not an obvious standard
form okay for instance we can rule a few
things out right what would you expect
if the primitive were to be a log
function what format should you expect
this to be in yeah so if you if you see
f dash on f okay then you be like okay I
know what to do with this because when
you integrate that you're going to get
log of whatever that that function is ok
that's ok all right but you don't have
that and you don't have something close
to that what's the problem yeah the
degree just totally mismatches so you've
got to reform and agree to this so you
have to differentiate twice to get there
okay now if it was degree 403 even from
off by some kind of closet that's fine
we can deal with constants you can
multiply and divide and that's all right
but you can't just multiply it by an X
here and then divide by an X out there
that just we've seen how that just goes
wrong okay so this is not what we have
what other kinds of options do we have
you known present a supreme sorceress
yeah
okay so you're suggesting this I'm going
to break your break apart again so well
okay let's just let's just write down
what you were saying so you said exon 1
plus x squared times X on 1 plus extra
suerte yeah and that's F dash well it's
a sort of F dash enough that's also sort
of F dash on earth right is this okay is
it hold on I'm you're just trying to
follow this logic right so I'm
integrating a product of two em dashes
or nefs okay so are we suggesting that
what this is going to be is log of one
thing x log of another plus a constant
is that work why not can we can we
articulate why this isn't this this is
not true okay why not gonna stop things
to integrate okay all right so hold on a
second this this line here we broke
apart the fashion and that's fine ok now
this we break up the fraction and it
busted why can we articulate is a little
more clear up think back to when we
first learn our rules for definite in
different integrals okay what's this is
a difference right or if you think about
it it's a sum of a negative thing okay
the integral of a when they write up
here into of a song is the same as the
sum of the integrals right and you can
think about that in terms of
differentiation right if you
differentiate x squared plus X you can
just take them separately and that's all
fine right what the derivative of a
product
right is not the product of the
derivatives it's not like okay 2x ok
close x I'm done right it's not that
simple and that's why we learnt the
product rule there is a whole such thing
as the product rule ok so unfortunately
this is also a bogus method but it was
worth a shot right you gotta try
something and we don't have any better
answers yet ok another suggestion any
other suggestions could you split up the
toppings instead of splitting up the
whole game you keep the denomination say
I'm please have to talk into 1 plus X
but 1 minus X square then you cancel out
yeah one that I flown by the sec sorry
so and that doesn't help either than
mine yeah okay so hold on let's just
stop for a second what were you what was
he trying to do I think what you were
trying to do is remind the numerator in
such a way so you can do some canceling
is that right yes the Cape didn't love
food but it didn't in what you suggested
didn't quite work ok however I think
we're onto something here ok I think we
do need to do some kind of rewriting of
this numerator ok in order to make it
fit with the denominator the real
problem is that square ok can you see
how that's the problem right because if
the squirrel wasn't there I'd be able to
deal with that ok um I can read these a
partner in a sufficient whale factorize
or whatever ok but with the square there
that it's back to what I reset the
degree is the problem and the tune
before they just started ok so how can i
write this in such a way that i can get
rid of things yeah
just pull out the everything squared
okay okay so you're suggesting the right
it is exon 1 plus x squared like that
and then that sets all squared we ought
to we ought to be suspicious because
that's that is closed right but the only
problem is this thing I differentiate it
and I can differentiate as five but the
problem I'm not presenting with this
integration so it's a different problem
now if I were to try and integrate this
right this is a function of function
there's a function and apply i'm
squaring it so function from you so in
order to make that work I need to have
the derivative of the inside function
there to make it be reverse chain okay
so it also happens to be bogus where
else could I go you don't need to phone
a friend okay because I cuz I'm right
here I'm going to show you okay so
before I before I reveal it to you right
this is this is my point the reason why
I'm trying to push you through this is
because you will get to this point and
you weren't just magically have a
teacher standing next to you say ah this
is a good idea okay so you have to
wrestle me what are you doing this
unfamiliar thing position of the two
sides all right so so here's where I'm
gonna do it okay now think back to a
question like say thank you for um if I
gave you something like X plus
oh let's do this
if I gave you that okay what would you
do what you do oh wait sorry Apollo I
think I want it upside down what I do
yes I want upside down so I try to get
that's what i meant around okay sorry
let's not again what would you do to
that now I've deliberately giving you
one which you can factorize neatly rad
this is X plus 2x plus 3 or this but
that doesn't help you does it right what
would you do instead bring what up where
do I take it what am i doing your tongue
what do you mean by bring it up fires of
bothers the nomination of any long how
do i multiply through
okay all right now so you know this part
of a pointing illustrating this is you
guys ate these questions for breakfast
right you like I know what to do with
these but you did like all set up like
30 of them and you just got into the
practice okay but now I give it to you
without context in your life what do we
do again it's not that hard you deny it
ok so that's already said okay so even
though factors into X plus 2x plus 3 I
don't factoring tnx was to an interest
rate doesn't help me because it doesn't
get rid of the denominator right can you
see how this is similar to this problem
yeah right so I need to put this into a
form where we'll divide through okay so
how do I do that again just remind me
what I'm actually going to do long
division so I'll go um why am I doing
this way and do this way okay nice one
okay what 15 seeks what do I do how's
your memory you're right then down the
down one you multiply and then you sorry
you multiply and then add you multiply
and then app what does this mean yes
okay all right so was it was a point of
this okay now i can rewrite my numerator
this e is X plus 4 times X plus 1 and
what does this mean it's just hanging
off on the side okay now what do I do
okay now this i can split I have a son
now you can break that apart then you
get some canceling and you're fine from
there all right now let's have a look at
this okay now you could sort of do
something similar right but do you
really need to do you really need to go
to these lengths how can you change the
numerator in such a way that it will
factorize and get rid of something on
the denominator think about it the
denominator is already factorized okay
okay so I could I could add one but of
course your chocolate can't just put
numbers in because you want to you've
got to subtract one so there's no net
change okay so this is fine I haven't
done I'm much around with this in any
dramatic way now what oh my god okay now
I don't let you settle on that I'm going
to come back to where I was writing this
originally okay and I'll show you what's
the quickest way to do this now that i
know this is the kind of trick that i'm
going to pull okay alright so here i
want to turn this around I actually
don't want this to be a minus okay so
i'm going to put a minus out there all
right this x squared minus one okay the
reason why is because i want this x
squared and this x squared to talk to
each other so that's why i pull out the
buzz all right now let's see what am i
right here now add my one okay so i've
got 1 plus x squared and that minus one
over there right it's actually up here
right in order to compensate for the one
I've just added this should become minus
2 UK with that not if I if I collected
my terms and go back to x squared minus
1 ok so that's all over 1 plus x squared
squared with respect to x
so there's that one plus X square that
I'm after and now I have a song
difference that I actually can break
apart thanks it was happening all right
brilliant some space look cute okay what
if I got on the left hand side I
actually have this evaluating thing
thanks four square bracket sorry X on 1
plus x squared 01 ok let's start let's
start to break this thing apart okay
what have I got here i'm going to have
minus and i'm going to write this as two
integrals now so i've got 1 plus x
squared on 1 plus x squared squared with
respect to X now that's a minus 2 and
there's a minus sign out the front yeah
so that becomes plus and I've got 2 over
1 plus x squared squared ok we okay
you're tracking so far thank you ok we
happy now yeah look at all right now you
can see why weird the thing that I
actually worked me out has appeared it's
here right it's just that I've got two
of them ok so we'll get to him in a
second ah let's leave him because I'm
going to have another thing to evaluate
between zero and one in a second some
items lump them together ok what's this
going to be when you do you're canceling
ok you're going to get not to one of
this now what is that it's just a
nervous this is why it appears in a
three in exam one between ok that's the
sole reason then what do I have here
I've got double off the actual integral
that I laughter 0 to 1 ok so that was
the high part now I just need to do a
little bit of rearranging but you can
see all the work really the hard thing
to see was this is where we got stuck
right we're trying to work out how we're
going to get out of this denominator
problem ok and this was the way we did
it ok so don't forget you don't just
have the option of multiplying dividing
by
closets to make things fit you can also
add and subtract things all right let's
let's let's tidy up okay this is what
I'm after so I'm going to put that I'm
going to make that the subject to not to
1 of 1 squared squared okay now what's
that equal to this is open this guy up
from lots 1 and here in coming over he's
now added so this is like you told me
it's tan inverse I'm not 21 ok now I'm
evaluating these two on the same
boundaries ok so i can actually write
that as one set upon one function if you
like to evaluate from more to 1 because
those 2r equipment now what do I have
here I've got double what I actually
weren't so might as well divide by two
at the same time which means there's a
half there okay all right left hand
sides fine that's that's actually what I
was after right so now i just finished
off in this tidy up ok let's evaluate it
at one which is the upper bound so what
am I going to get I'll get one on one
plus one plus tan inverse of 1 which is
there's my upper bound let's do the roll
bound as well i get 0 on I don't care 0
0 k plus tan inverse of Z which is 0 ok
halftime all that
and then you can go home okay well
actually not quite i can essentially not
the actual last question there's a
second last question so don't go yet but
anyways you can get it all right so can
we review all right um it's not a fairly
gently okay and then you think I can I
know I need to integrate both sides and
then we need to rearrange you have to be
super careful okay one of the common
things that people will do is they're
like ah you know I know I need to
factorize this out somehow but that
doesn't work you quickly realize that
you can't just do a pretty easy
straightforward thing you have to do a
weird thing right so some people I kid
you not okay because he is running out
of time and you're panicking you're
thinking I must have done something
wrong it has to it has to factorize out
somehow that's probably a lot of minus
it's probably a plus that works and then
you get 1 over it cancels and the like
sweet you're done okay and then you'll
get actually you actually get its not
equal because you evaluate this develop
that means it's not sure okay so pay
careful attention to what you end up
with here I know that you've got plenty
of tools in your toolbox for actually
breaking apart intervals so you can put
them into forms that you can work with
okay